name's Alan Barry Allen this is a party
for criminals it's my stories up to
something
fighting zone okay what do we do
your battles a good show you know and
all the hub of saving your keisters I
never got to ask what the hell you were
doing down there a 1940's no one says
keisters Nash if you would just tell us
what you're looking for down there we
might be able to help you all right
tomorrow morning 9 o'clock tunnels
bringing all fancy team why should we do
that
because I know how to save Barry Allen
[Music]
you must be the monitor how do you know
it has no human would actually wear
something so ridiculous you ate for the
world you lost and ibises the power to
restore it you can bring back where's
the recovery of your universe will
require a single task
what kind of task
you must betray Oliver Queen
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my video for the flash
season 6 episode 6 trailer crisis on
Infinite Earths scenes from arrow and
flash this week and the new Batman news
for Robert Pattinson zhh Batman they
just confirmed a couple big characters
so we'll break it all down there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs in this too
in teasers for crisis on Infinite Earths
we're still doing that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about crisis on Infinite Earths
on the video I'll start with a trailer
in the footage then I'll talk about the
Batman stuff so just careful for
spoilers for the flash and arrow this
week if you have not seen those episodes
as you can see they're doing a James
Bond style episode they even have James
Bond music playing under it with
elongated man teaming up with the flash
which means that they'll probably tease
more of the suit did nice storyline any
time one of the other side characters
gets paired up with the flash for the
main storyline they always get to push
way deeper on whatever their arc is for
the season and for him it's just the
suit didney arc and as you can see
they're bringing back the ultraviolet
villain from episode 2 so there might be
some more Easter eggs for a black hole
from the flash rebirth comics but we
start with Nash wells saying that he has
a plan to save Barry Allen so the whole
idea is that he seems the kind of a
dirtbag at first but they're slowly
winning him over to the team he doesn't
want to have anything to do with the
council of Wells but he wants that sweet
sweet eternium honey that apparently the
monitor is either hoarding or has access
to because why else would he be trying
to follow the monitor because Joe
mentions the monitor knee says you know
Mar novo and he gets ready to give him
this big explainer before elongated man
comes and stops him so it sounds like he
might try to steal some eternium from
the monitor and there also might be
something in his special secret stash
that can help them save Barry the whole
thing with eternium from the comic books
is that it's actually shards from the
rock of eternity which is a huge Suzanne
in Black Adam Easter Egg I don't know
how much they're gonna get into that
during the crossover so maybe just some
small Easter eggs for the Shazam
characters because I don't expect to see
the rock or Zachary Levi pop up in the
crossover the whole thing with the arrow
scenes is that Oliver is actually trying
to build a weapon to destroy the monitor
if he turns on them as the prophecy he
got last week foretold there was a book
that belonged to the League of Assassins
thousands of years ago the monitor
visited someone from the League of
Assassins and they recorded in his
journal that he thought that he might be
responsible
for the coming calamity quote-unquote
crisis on Infinite Earths so Oliver is
operating on the assumption that the
monitor might double-cross them at some
point he doesn't know anything about the
anti-monitor yet they haven't give him
that explainer yet so without any
context Oliver pushes forward giving a
sample to analyze a fabric that had been
grazed by the antimatter wave that
destroyed earth to a couple weeks ago
remember the whole reason that Oliver
was there was to steal dwarf star
particles for something that the monitor
was building and it might be the cosmic
towers that appear during crisis on
Infinite Earths he might be building a
version of that but you also have to
consider that that prophecy might become
self-fulfilling and if Oliver's actions
he takes to avoid the monitor going
crazy on them actually lead to the
monitor going crazy on them then you
have that big twist seen with Black
Canary being visited by someone who
looks like the monitor saying that she
could get earth to back it's in my power
all you have to do is betray Oliver
Queen
he even looks like he kind of has a
smirk on his face while he's telling her
that like he enjoys the idea that she
might betray Oliver which does not
characteristically seem like the Marno
vu monitor that we've seen the last
couple of years so either the monitor is
lying to everyone about preventing
crisis on Infinite Earths
and he's double-crossing them or this is
not the monitor Marno vu and it's really
the anti-monitor masquerading as him or
at some other rogue monitor that might
wind up becoming the anti-monitor if
you've never read comic book crisis on
Infinite Earths these monitors are a
race of beings that all look like this
they all have the weird chops and the
jowls they have the weird haircuts but
they do have subtle differences in their
faces in hairstyles the TV show might
just be changing that in order to
mislead us so that you think that this
is the monitor but surprise twist it
winds up being someone else
remember Martian Manhunter 's brother is
kind of evil and he's a shapeshifter so
there is an evil shape-shifter that
could be working with the anti-monitor
to mislead the heroes also fun fact
during crisis on Infinite Earths the
actor who's playing the monitor this
person here is also playing the
anti-monitor when he goes full comic
book anti-monitor looking like the
mobius from the comics from the
antimatter universe he just posted this
behind-the-scenes picture a little while
ago now that doesn't confirm that this
is the anti-monitor but in the comics
harbinger who's played by lilah
the TV show gets mind-controlled by the
anti-monitor in his force to kill the
monitor so Superman and all the heroes
that are left are forced to find a way
to fight the anti-monitor by themselves
without the monitors help but in the
comics the monitor and the anti-monitor
are two completely different characters
there's nobody masquerading as the
anti-monitor he always looked like this
with the crazy face but early theory if
this isn't a shapeshifter
maybe Oliver's antimatter weapon gets
used on the anti-monitor and instead of
killing him it's supercharges him and
makes his face look like this but it
still doesn't explain what happens to
the monitor because in all these big
fight scenes I have not seen the monitor
charging the field with them it's just
the heroes versus the anti-monitor
so either at some point they wind up
killing him off like they did in the
comics or he winds up turning into the
anti-monitor which would be a big twist
but moving into Batman news so the big
news about the Batman movie is that Andy
Serkis is being locked down as their new
Alfred I was super surprised when I saw
this interesting choice not somebody who
I would have expected for that role I
would have expected him for a role that
required more prosthetics like the
penguin or something else or one of the
villains from his rogues gallery but I
do think that he can do a great job with
a character because he has done a lot
more darker noir movies and television
shows and that seems like it's gonna be
the tone of the new Batman film the
other thing they just announced is
probably even bigger they just announced
that Colin Farrell is being locked down
as their new Oswald Cobblepot penguin
which again is not someone I would have
ever thought of for that role normally
when you think of Colin Farrell you
think of it maybe as a Harvey Dent
two-face but there's no mention of what
he would look like and if they'd use any
prosthetics or motion capture to modify
his face to give him more of a
comic-book penguin look so of no idea
what he's actually going to look like as
that character but currently right now
they have Robert Pattinson as the Batman
Jeffrey Wright as Commissioner Gordon
not detective Gordon apparently he's
supposed to be Commissioner Gordon when
this story begins in there doing the
Batman the Animated Series thing where
all of the villains like two-face
Riddler penguin are already operating in
Gotham City when the story begins
they're not going to start with their
origin stories and build them up you'll
already see penguin being full penguin
and Riddler being full Riddler when the
story begins they just announced zoe
kravitz is there Selina Kyle Catwoman
and then I'll be
Paul Dino as their Edward Nash tune
Riddler he just the original version of
the comic-book Riddler I've already done
a video about that so I'll link it at
the end of this they're still looking
for their Harvey Dent two-face he will
be in the movie and they'll probably
announced that before the end of the
year there will be other minor
characters they announced after they
start shooting they usually don't cast
those minor roles till right before they
need them to shoot those scenes but they
will confirm all the mains really soon
and after that give us the first look at
Robert Pattinson snoo Batman costume the
costume designer that they got is the
one that did the original blade movie
he's done Star Wars in the new Star Trek
movies a whole bunch of other stuff so
he's pretty solid he'll probably make a
pretty cool Batman costume and given
that it's more of a detective thriller
and wash story I'm expecting the new
Batman suit to be way more toned down
and less armor looking than the last few
versions from say Christian Bale's Dark
Knight Batman and Ben Affleck's bat suit
even though he did have a very cloth
looking version of the suit his version
of Batman was just way more hulking in
giant than the Robert Pattinson version
is going to be I would say his new bat
suit is gonna be even less armor looking
than Michael Keaton's Batman suits I'd
be totally cool if they wanted to go
with the classic blue and gray but I
think that they'll probably stick with
black post all your theories in the
comments below
what do you think that Robert Pattinson
snoo Batman's suit is going to look like
which version are they going to be
mostly inspired by congratulations tebya
smolka you're the giveaway winner from
my last big flash video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details
everyone click here for the brand-new
Rick and Morty's season 4 trailer and
click here for that new Batman Riddler
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]